[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to the 2018
Android developer summits here at the
historic Computer History Museum in
California this is an event for
developers by developers with tons of
in-depth content and most importantly
direct access to the engineers that
actually build Android in fact we have
so many of them here this week that I'm
pretty sure Android development is gonna
stop in the audience we have attendees
from over 70 countries both in person
and on the livestream we're glad to have
you all with us here today
now speaking of history it was we're
sitting about to celebrate our 10th
anniversary of Android and in fact it
was about 10 years ago
that the very first customers were
unboxing their g1 devices and CNET's
review at the time said thanks to the
openness of the operating system there's
huge potential for the g1 and any
Android devices after it to become
powerful mini computers for as
developers create more applications for
Google Android the g1 did ok but it's
what came next and what you built on
Android that fundamentally changed the
mobile industry 10 years ago the mobile
landscape looked very different mobile
platforms at the time were not friendly
to developers with severely limited
api's and tools but even more
problematic was that each OS required
completely different and non
transferable skills so it was simply
impossible to build a mobile app at
scale now at the same time off in a
corner of Google in building 44 a small
team of dedicated engineers we're
quietly working on what at the time
seemed like a crazy project the idea was
bold to build a new open source
operating system that any device maker
could use with a powerful SDK that put
developers first and to many of the time
this seemed like a harebrained idea
what did Google know about
telecommunications and how could it
possibly influence this established
industry it was an intense time for the
Android team and to add to the drama
while getting close to launching version
Wado
Apple announced the iPhone and it looked
awesome
they brought their a-game so what were
we gonna do well we had two hardware
programs at the time the Sooner device
with a physical keyboard and the dream
device which included a touchscreen so
we had no choice but to Excel accelerate
the schedule of the dream we felt like
we had a window to deliver on our vision
of the smartphone before it was too late
we were racing to launch and the team
was incredibly motivated so we started a
tradition of putting on a huge breakfast
on Sundays in building 44 for anyone who
wanted to come in bacon eggs pastries
you name it and it was super productive
no meetings just coding and in parallel
book thrashing and release planning
clearly these cats do not know about
Android studio as code completion in the
morning you'd have a previous week's
version of Android but by the evening
some amazing new piece of functionality
would appear like the notification shade
or a new home screen it was like
watching the OS come alive before your
eyes
now one of the big challenges in
creating a new platform is the
bootstrapping problem so how do you
motivate anyone to write an application
for a platform with zero users and why
would a user buy a phone with no
applications so we did two things first
the core Android team wrote mobile app
versions of Google's desktop services
everything from Gmail to maps to you
chew and it worked out well because
it'll let us experience our api's and
framework at the same time as developing
the applications and it's something that
I like to encourage we do to this day
but to make the platform shy and we
needed apps from across the industry so
we launched an early look SDK in
November 2007 and announced the Android
developer challenge
with twenty million dollars to be
awarded to the top 100 apps and
developers around the world responded
and by April 2008 just six months later
we had over two thousand submissions and
it was amazing given that there were no
physical devices to use for developments
just the emulator the apps were
surprisingly diverse from games to
social networking and from utilities to
productivity tools and location and GPS
were the top used features along with
camera and media and messaging so it
really showed this pent-up demand for
developers to be creative on mobile and
to use features that were up to now
locked down to them some of the winning
apps are still around today like life
360 and several paved the way for absent
businesses that would come years later
the t-mobile g1 launched in October 2008
with Android Market this was the
predecessor to Google Play and it had
just over 50 apps on day one one week
later we opened this door for developer
uploads and advanced capabilities like
in our purchases and direct carrier
billing and just broader country support
we're yet to be built the following 10
years was one of rapid evolution in the
early days we were doing two big
releases a year and our lead program
manager at the time ade this offhand
suggestion that we codenamed the
releases after deserts in alphabetical
order and that ideas stuck and here's
what came next
so Android 1.5 cupcake we were eating a
lot of cupcakes at the time added
virtual keyboard support so we'd no
longer require that physical keyboard
like on the first g1 device we also
added the copy and paste clipboard
Android 1.6 donut followed introducing
support for different screen densities
and sizes thereby laying the foundation
for a variety of phone sizes and for
factors that were going to come up a
couple of years later and that was
Dianne Hackborn zai dia she's generally
about five years ahead of the rest of us
Android 2 Eclair introduced powerful
speech recognition and changed driving
forever
Google Maps notification avek
Android 2.2 Froyo took the speech
capabilities to the next level with
voice actions which lets you perform key
functions on your phone like getting
directions and taking notes and setting
alarms and of course was the precursor
to today's Google Assistant Android 2.3
Gingerbread was in many ways the first
mainstream version of Android and it was
the one that started to get serious
scale with hardware manufacturers when
Android 3 honeycomb we added support for
tablets with the holo theme but now we
had a problem because phones were
shipping on Gingerbread and toddlers
were shipping on honeycomb so we merged
both form factors with Android for Ice
Cream Sandwich and in that release we
also introduced more intuitive
navigation with the use of gestures to
dismiss notifications and recent apps
and that release was also saw the
arrival of quick settings Android
jellybean was an incremental release
that included project butter to optimize
graphics to get a buttery smooth vsync
locked animations and smooth animations
are something that I personally obsess
about to this day Android KitKat came
with projects felt that reduce the
memory footprint to 512 megabytes and it
also included DSP offload at OK Google
hot word I heard a beep there it works
Android 5 lollipop followed and was the
mother of all releases it brought
material design to a droid it giving it
an entirely that you look and feel and
so between project butter and material
design we changed the narrative on
Android giving it a beautiful refined
user experience lollipop also introduced
support for new categories of computing
including wearables and auto and TV and
lollipop was the first release with
enterprise features such as the work
profile which we've been building on
ever since lollipop was such an epic
release that we frankly needed to spend
our energy in Android 6 marshmallow on
improving quality we also made a major
overhaul of privacy in that release with
the introduction of runtime permissions
Androids Avenue God brought significant
new capabilities including multi wind
support virtual reality and um OG
Android a Oreo introduced a droid go
profile for entry-level smartphones and
it also came a project travel a massive
overhaul of the hardware interface layer
to help out speed up and reduce the cost
of doing upgrades finally this year we
launched Android Pi which starts our
journey on an AI first experience it
also contains tons of UI improvements
and simplifications and introduces the
concept of digital well being so that
was a very quick trip down memory lane I
think it's pretty incredible to see just
how far we have all come in a decade of
smartphone development and while we're
solving different problems today it's
clear the principles upon which we built
Android are just as true today as they
we're ten years ago so principles like
giving developers a powerful SDK so
their apps can run everywhere or open
source code to enable device makers from
entry level to high-end and an ever
improving you acts that delights users
around the world so what is the next ten
years have in store for Android well I
honestly don't have a crystal ball but
there are three trends that I want to
call out that I think are important one
smartphones are getting smarter too
multi-screen computing is becoming
pervasive but exciting new form factors
on the horizon and three our phones are
going to be able to help us with safety
and digital well-being so first our
smartphones are about to get a whole lot
smarter
AI will enable your phone to get to know
you better to adapt to you and to become
more personal and you can already see
glimpses of this in android pi running
on google pixel for example the screen
brightness automatically learns your
preferences and the next Absalon char
predicted with high accuracy to save you
time and the camera is able to recognize
objects in real time with google lands
and the phone can stream calls with an
intelligent AI for developers wanting to
tap into AI we announced ml kit earlier
this year so whether you're new or
experienced in machine learning ml kit
enables everything from image labeling
to face detection and
or m/l KITT builds on androids neural
networks API which provides hardware
acceleration by DSPs and that neural
processing units or NP use and it's
important on the latest flagship devices
from Huawei Xiaomi oneplus Google and
more in an API boost performance
considerably so for example mobile net
which is a family of vision models for
tensorflow
runs eight times faster using nn API on
the Qualcomm Snapdragon 845 compared to
the CPU and you can expect and queues to
become standard on all smartphone
silicon in the next few years the second
trend goes beyond phones we're investing
heavily in a multi-screen experience
this means a great Android experience
across TVs wearables cars and
Chromebooks and we're seeing user growth
in all of these form factors for example
user engagement on android TV has grown
to three hours per device per day and
this year Android auto has seen 250%
user growth and our partners launched 19
new watches running where OS and just
when you thought you'd seen everything
in phones we're about to see a whole new
form factor idea from Android device
makers foldables they take advantage of
new flexible display technology so the
screen can literally Bend and fold and
you can think of the device really as
both a phone and a tablet and broadly
we're seeing two variants there's the
two screen devices and the one screen
devices when folded it looks like a
phone so it fits in your pocket or purse
and the defining feature for this form
factor is something we call screen
continuity for example you might start a
video on the folded smaller screen while
on the go but later sit-down I want a
more immersive experience so you can
simply unfold the device to get a larger
tablet sized screen and as you unfold
the app seamlessly transfers to the
bigger screen without missing a beat
it's an exciting concept and we expect
to see foldable devices from several
Android manifest
in fact we're already working closely
with Samsung on a new device they plan
to launch early next year which you'll
hear about later today for our part
we're enhancing Android to take
advantage of this new form factor
what does little work as possible from
you for example we're adding resizable
flags so your app can respond to folding
and unfolding and we expect to see a lot
of innovation and foldable Hardware over
the next few years and we're excited to
see what you come up with the third
trend is safety and well-being
smartphones have gone from non-existent
to indispensable in just 10 years
in fact the very idea of leaving your
home without your smartphone literally
sends shivers down people's spines and
at Google we like to build products that
give you utility and whether that's
putting the world's information at your
fingertips or navigating you to where
you need to be or translating a foreign
language but beyond utility we feel a
responsibility to your safety and
well-being as one example more than 80%
of emergency calls originate from mobile
phones however locating these phones in
an emergency can be challenging since
traditional emergency location
technologies often fail indoors or have
a radius that's too large in a serious
emergency minutes can mean the
difference between life and death we
launched androids emergency location
service Els in 2016 and just recently
announced bringing it to the US would
Els when you dial nine-one-one
or your country's equivalent your
location is accurately calculated
through a combination of Wi-Fi cell
towers and GPS signals and sent directly
to the emergency provider Els is
built-in to 99% of Android phones all
the way back to version 4 and we're
continuing to look at new ways to help
improve your safety with lots of ideas
in the works now having a smart phone
with you all day is awesome but we also
want to make sure you're in control of
your digital well being and we know from
our research that 72% of people are
concerned with the amount of time they
spend on tech so what Android pie this
year we have
juice you tools to let you control your
usage with things like app limits
greyscale wind down and do not disturb
the blocks all distractions of course
like most features we've added developer
hooks so you can now tell if Do Not
Disturb is enabled or if your app is
temporarily limited and you can
implement an intent filter so your app
has its own usage dashboard we're
continuing to invest in this space with
lots of enhancements plans
ok so let's wrap up Android from the
beginning was conceived as a platform
built around developers we poured a ton
of energy into growing this ecosystem
and community from the ground up I see
our developer tools and frameworks as
living breathing things so we're
constantly striving to be better and in
return you've been an amazing community
building incredible apps and services
that enable into the light users the
world over we simply could not do this
without you so thank you so with that
let's get down to business I'm excited
to head over to Stephan team to talk
about some of the recent work we've been
doing to increase developer productivity
on Android thank you
the matoke was started as an app which
lets you browse digital menus now we are
this Bigfoot tech company in that is
operational in 24 countries more than
hundred 50 million users this is the
platform every month we have available
in ten languages and on the delivery
side we have a fleet of around 60,000
delivery riders after all the buzz in
the developer community about Cortland I
was intrigued by how godling was able to
uphold the object-oriented paradigm and
solve many of the architectural flaws in
the compiled time itself I almost
instantly recognized that Kotlin will
enable me to develop more
architecturally sound applications
almost all the new SDKs and API is that
Google is releasing right now has got a
limb support if you convert a Java class
to Catalan there will be about 15 to 20
percent decrease in the line of code but
if you take data classes there is a
drastic improvement of about 55 percent
decrease in the lines of code switching
to Catalan is efficient and really
exciting at the bottom now almost every
new feature is being developed in Gatlin
I would recommend switching to Kotlin
because of its interoperability with
Java with recent updates Android studio
has drastically improved
Gotland support it is almost
frictionless
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone I'm Steph I'm on the Android
team and Dave is right
developers influence the platform you're
not on top of it you're a part of what
we do Colin's a great example it's not a
Google designed language was not maybe
the obvious choice but it was the best
choice as you made clear we could see
developers voting with their feet in the
adoption in the months before we
announced support like Kotlin our
developer investments come down to two
things at heart
number one your feedback and number two
Google engineers using Android and
thinking how do I make something people
will love so the past several years
we've been investing deeply in androids
developer experience it's been guided by
your feedback we'll talk about that
we're also going to talk about some new
things that we have to share so each
year we've been investing let's start
with IDs in 2013 we first demoed Android
studio at i/o was a new IDE built on
IntelliJ designed to accelerate Android
development over five years we've
progressively built it out based on the
features you asked for most completely
new emulators a new compiled Tweel chain
profilers mobile layout tools like
constraint layout better C++ inspectors
for things like layouts and app size and
tools for every dessert release we also
wanted to add the little things that
make a big difference whether that's
maven integration tool in checks second
api's in 2016 Dianne Hackborn wrote a
famous post on a parka tech chure saying
we're not opinionated to which you
replied
please be opinionated so we created
architecture components and we've
refined them with feedback over many
eaps and expanded them now into Android
jetpack we see jetpack as the future of
our mobile ap is they are opinionated
and easy to use intuitive api's that
work on 95% of devices we want them to
integrate seamlessly with androids core
primitives so you get the best possible
combination
efficiency everyday and also deep
control expect to see us continue
expanding jetpack every year third was
languages in 2017 we announced support
for Kotlin we've added since then IDE
support API support Docs samples and
moved it into the Kotlin foundation
working with the wonderful language
authors fourth app delivery so
developers have always loved the Play
Store for the fast delivery times that's
great when you want to launch and
innovate fast but you told us app sizes
way too big and that really hurts
install so this year we announced the
app bundle and dynamic delivery
developers using this our slimming down
apps worldwide with most apps saving up
to and over 30% finally security Android
was built with security in mind from day
one with application sandboxing as
androids matured we've expanded our
mobile security services today 99% of
abusive apps are taken down before
anyone can install and after you install
we use Google Play protect to scan over
50 billion apps per day every kind of
app on every connected device we find a
potentially harmful app we disable it or
we remove it but let's say you're doing
everything right and you accidentally
get caught in this net without someone
to talk to this is a place I think we
need to do better we need to make it
much easier for you to reach us in these
cases so our our engineering director
will be here tomorrow at the fireside
chat to talk with you about it and get
your feedback now another way we protect
the ecosystem is moving apps the target
current API is like API 26 by November
and you told us ok makes sense but
please give us a long notice period so
that's why we gave almost a year's
notice we think of you as a part of how
we work whether it's early ideas to
advisory boards reading reddit threads
beta and iterating after launch we
really want to be trustworthy and we've
I only heard about things that you loved
like architecture components and Kotlin
sometimes we have underestimated the
time it takes to get things right like
instant run what we've heard is you want
from us open sharing so your can see
things that are early as long as we're
clear this is early as well as things
that are ready for production so that's
what we'll do today let's shift gears
today I'm gonna share a range of early
ideas all the way to stable releases I
want to walk you through two big themes
for Android development first
foundations using languages and
libraries to work smarter second
productivity using mobile ID ease
console and distribution to develop
easier have higher quality apps and to
grow adoption we're gonna start with
foundations and kahlan throughout I
wanted you to hear from some of the
people who have been instrumental in
these projects so we're gonna start with
someone who was key in the Kotlin
decision he's a huge contributor to
Android both while he was in the
community now on the Google team it's a
privilege to turn things over to Jake
Wharton
[Music]
hey everyone so I'm Jake I'm part of the
team working on cotton for Android and
it's been 18 months since Steph was on
stage at Google i/o just down the road
from here announcing that Colin would be
supported as a new first-class language
so something that had never been done in
the history of Android but based on
positive feedback from developers like
you and the growing adoption that we've
seen in apps it's clear that this was
the right choice
according to github nearly stats Kotlin
is the number one fastest growing
language in terms of contributors Stack
Overflow is a yearly survey places
Kotlin as number two most loved
programming language by those who
participated for android 46 percent of
pro android developers are now using
Kotlin to build their apps this was
according to a survey of those visiting
developer.android.com in October we had
a hundred and eighteen thousand seven
day active projects using Colin in the
Android studio this is based on those
who opted into reporting analytics
that's a 10x increase from the numbers
last year now when Colin sport was
announced there already were a bunch of
apps that were using it in the Play
Store and that group continues to grow
and includes new apps like WeChat Amazon
Kindle and Twitter just prior to Google
i/o this year the Colin language moved
into the colin foundation and we're
fortunate to partner with JetBrains who
spend a tremendous amount of resources
on improving the language itself just
last week they released the newest
version of collin 1.3 with new language
features api's bug fixes and performance
improvements for example inline classes
which in most cases don't actually
allocate like a normal class would
unless they're boxed for constrained
devices that we target avoiding
allocation while still retaining type
safety is a big win the Colin sustainer
library now includes a set of unsigned
numbers such as u int and you bite and
you long and these are built using that
inline class feature and in addition to
Collin code targeting Android or the JVM
you can now target JavaScript or now
native code as well this unlocks the
possibility of reusing parts of your
code
on more platforms and finally the
long-awaited co-routine support is now
stable in 1.3 which is a lighter-weight
version of threading the language and
library support for co-routines combined
and simplify how you do asynchronous
operations or perform concurrent work
things that are essential to every
Android app and as I'm sure you are
we're looking forward to using these new
Kotlin features in the column specific
API is that we provide so far the
majority of those have been through the
kahlan extensions which are part of
jetpack at this year this year at i/o we
announced that the column extensions
were expanding from just core KTX to
seven KTX libraries for common artifacts
that you use from jetpack like fragments
sequel a lifecycle and all of these are
now available as stable releases since
then though as new api's are added to
existing libraries or new libraries are
added to jetpack the KTX extensions are
being built alongside so things like
navigation paging and slices are all new
libraries that each have extensions
being built with them and we're starting
to go beyond just providing extensions
so life cycle is going to support a
co-routine scope so you can easily
launch go routines and have automatic
cancellation and work manager will be
offering a work object based on
co-routines and we're always on the
lookout for integrations like these that
provide more close interoperability if
you want to get started with seco
routines on android there's a new code
lab that you can work through it covers
performing asynchronous work testing of
co-routines and the work manager
integration and since Colin isn't just a
language for building Android apps
Google cloud platform now offers samples
tutorials and their own code lab so you
can build your application back-end
using Kotlin and finally new Udacity
courses are available in preview today
which cover app development entirely in
Kotlin and they use both jetpack and
popular third-party libraries to speak
more about jetpack as a whole I'd like
to turn it over to Ramon
[Applause]
[Music]
I am hon I work on the Android from our
team so few months ago we announced
jetpack to next generation of Android
tools and API is to accelerate Android
application development jetpack builds
on the foundation that we laid out with
support library and app architecture
components but we also add new tools and
libraries to the mix jetpack is about
writing less code and targeting more
devices all jetpack libraries are
backwards compatible and target up to
95% of existing Android devices we first
started running early access programs on
architecture components about two years
ago and they entered in our first public
beta was 18 months ago at Google i/o
2017 today out of the top 1,000
applications in active development on
Play Store 798 already using jetpack
this is up from about 560 at Google i/o
this year jetpack is used in many
applications like New York Times Kakao
Talk jus lingo Evernote uber SoundCloud
Pandora Twitter Dropbox viber and many
more
ABB's build all over the world in India
Germany France Korea Israel China the US
and more also at i/o we announced new
libraries for paging navigation work
manager slices and cutting extensions
which was talked about although these
are still in early phases of development
they are already being used in over
38,000 applications worldwide and the
evolution of those Android X Diaries is
driven in large part by the feedback we
receive from you the community but we
know that many of you have not expressed
a desire to do more than simply be
feedback so that's why this summer we
moved all Android X development to
public USB you can now see features and
bug fixes implemented in real time and
you can contribute to any of the Android
X Ivory's all you need is Android studio
and the public has DK and we also want
to use a OSP as a place where we can
experiment and prototype new ideas in
our hope is that early access to Android
features will help us refine and help
chip even better libraries so please
join us we get back we introduced to
architecture component libraries
navigation and work manager the
navigation architecture component
library offers a simplified way to
implement Android navigation principles
in your applique
using a single activity distortions give
you consistent animations across devices
atomic navigation operations and easier
transitive animated transitions work
manager makes it easy to perform
background tasks in the most efficient
manner possible
you do not need to wonder whether you
should be using Java dispatcher job
scheduler or a laminator work manager
will figure out which is the best
solution given yet the application state
and the device API level these two
libraries will become better later this
month so if you have any feedback about
those api's the engineering teams are
here today and tomorrow so now is the
time to give that give us that feedback
we also introduced Android slices a new
way to bring users to your applications
sets these are like a mini snippet to
surface contents outside of your
application this can help users book a
flight play video color ride and so on
slice is another example where we want
to be open very early but we want to
take the time to get things right after
working with several of you on the api's
we're moving into public EAP at the at
the end of the month we do is kayak and
many other applications we will run
experiments surfacing slices in Google
search results and there's a session
today with more info and best practices
about building slices so please check it
out
our team has also been hard at work
bringing numerous improvements to
existing Android flex X libraries for
instance in paging 2.1 you have more
control over memory usage and it offers
better kirtland integration room 2.1 is
our biggest feature launch since 100 we
added full text search tables database
views better our java no.2 value
integration data binding three points
who brings much faster multi module
compilation and we expect further
improvements in three point four and
finally view model let's receive state
in OS p one thing you told us work
pretty well was deeply integrating
libraries and tools in android
constraint lead was one example but a
new great example of this is navigation
so in android shows three point three we
have a new navigation editor to helps
you easily understand visualize
visualize and build an educated
navigation flow in your application so
let's go straight to a demo of the
narration editor so here i have an
application that was already partially
written and you can already see the flow
of navigation through the different
screens of the application
so if I run the demo on the emulator and
we wait for Gradle to do its job I can
click on leaderboards I can see
different profiles but if I click on the
profile nothing happens I can go back to
the editor add a new screen so I just
select the fragments to the user
profiles and then I'll link the
leaderboard screen to the user profile I
also need to add an arguments for the
selected user and string I just rerun
the app wait for Grado the toastie more
you want to chat with me after this we
go back to the board and if I click on
the profile now I can see the profile
but as I go back and forth between those
two screens you can see that there are
no animations no transitions so if I go
back to the editor and I select this
navigation flow I can choose which
animations I want so when I choose the
enter animations and the exit animations
and now if I rerun yet one last time go
back to leaderboards and now you can see
the sliding transition so if you want to
play with the data
so if you want to play with a navigation
editor all you have to do is download
Android studio from the beta Channel
today and and get started as we expand
the Android jetpack libraries and tools
together we're focused on your feedback
about the top 5 areas that you encounter
so please let us know we want to know
about animations UI themes and styles
camera anything else we are here today
we are here tomorrow you can tell us
what you need from us and with that I
would like to turn it over to Karen we
will let will let you know that our
plans for Android studio Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Karen I'm on the team that builds
Android studio and Android jetpack so
Ramon and Jake just talked you through
the language and library experiences to
build on top of that I'm going to talk
to you about productivity and what we're
doing with Android studio four three two
we asked ourselves what can we do to
have a meaningful impact on productivity
and where do you spend the most your
time we heard loud and clear
thanks form on but it's build speed it's
something that you do every day you set
me up it's something you do every day
multiple times a day and every minute
that you're waiting for that bill to
finish we know it's a minute wasted so
we took a deep look at our data to see
what was going on and we actually found
two things to be true the first thing we
found was that build speeds in our
opt-in data is actually getting slower
over time the second thing we found is
that new releases of studio are actually
improving build times in the last year
and a half we saw build speeds get
faster by 42% on fresh projects so
something's going on and we had to take
a deeper look code bases are just
getting larger custom plugins are adding
to build times annotation processors
that everyone you people use are
negating the benefit of incremental
builds new languages can add to
compilation times and if you have many
modules resource management can add time
as well the ecosystem and project growth
are kind of outgrowing our build
improvements we are committed to making
build faster you'll find a large part of
the team on build here this week to
listen and learn and to tell you more
about what we're doing we want to get
this right and we need your help to do
it
we're giving ourselves stretch goals
we're working on attribution tools to
help you better understand what's
impacting your build in your projects
and we're making Gradle and our first
party plugins faster we also know that
iteration speed is super important app
development because it's all about
trying things out iterating and then
failing fast and then doing it again
with instant run we want to fix what we
started and quickly apply changes
without losing the fate of your app part
of that apply changes is around
deployment times so we know they play a
huge part and we've just shipped an
update and Android Pi where we're seeing
a big difference in real
and sample projects between PI and Oreo
if you're using USB 3 o versus USB 2 oh
we've seen sometimes that close see that
seemed close to that emulator speed
please let us know if you're interested
in giving us early feedback to get apply
changes right we're starting an EAP very
soon that takes us to emulators because
we want to make it eration speed faster
we're investing in emulators for every
OS at i/o we showed the ability to save
a snapshot of your current state of your
emulator and boot up and switch to any
snapshot in under two seconds
productivity is also about making the
hard problems easier we heard that it's
really hard to make to see how your app
is impacting battery life on the phone
so we built the new energy profiler in
three two you can now see way clocks
visualize the estimated battery usage of
system components and inspect background
events that contribute to battery drain
the new beta for Android studio 3 3 is
available today and was just released
moments ago we know that in order for an
ID to be delightful and to keep you
productive it has to be not just stable
but it has to be rock solid stable
because of the number of hours that you
spend there the main focus for our next
few releases will be quality which we're
calling project marble reducing the
number of crashes hangs and memory leaks
fixing user impacting bugs and investing
our infrastructure and tools we know
that sometimes we've missed memory leaks
before we shipped so we're building
tools to help detect those leaks before
they even happen Dave mentioned how
millions of Android apps already run on
Chromebooks we're bringing the full
power of Android studio as an officially
supported IDE to Chrome OS early next
year if you'd like to try it today you
can learn more at developer.android.com
now I'd like to invite Matt Henderson up
to share more about app size and what
we're doing with the Android app bundle
[Music]
thanks Karen and hi everybody so I work
on developer tools like the play console
and I wanted to start by talking about
app size apps have grown dramatically in
size the average is up five times since
2012 but larger size carries a cost it
reduces the install conversion rate and
it increases uninstall rate now you told
us that using multi apk to configure
different app versions was a painful way
to reduce app size so the Android app
bundle makes it much simpler using the
app bundle we reduce size by generating
an apk for the languages the screen
density the CPU architecture that each
user needs and it's working well size
reductions vary on average apps as
seeing a 35% reduction in size compared
to a universal apk now with the recent
stable release of Android studio 3.2 at
bundles in production have taken off
they're up ten times thousands of
developers have embraced a bundles and
the number of bundles and production now
total billions of installs and Google's
apps they're switching to YouTube Google
Maps photos Google News are all in
production with app bundles today photos
for example is now 40% smaller so we're
really excited about the app bundles
potential we sign apks for delivery to
the end-user this is highly secure we
protect your key in the same memory that
in the same storage we protect Google's
own keys this signing step is critical
it allows us to process the app bundle
in order to generate the optimized
and this in turn allows you to benefit
from additional optimizations in the
future starting right now so I'm happy
to announce that the app bundle now
supports uncompressed native libraries
this utilizes an existing Android
platform feature that was little used
because in the past you would have had
to use multi apk for pre m and post M
devices now we just do it for you with
no additional developer work needed the
app bundle now makes apps using native
libraries an average of 8 percent
smaller to download and 16 percent
smaller on disk for m+ devices by adding
dynamic feature modules to your app
bundle you can load any app
functionality on demand instead of at
install time for example you don't need
to send that same big feature to 100% of
your users if it's only going to be used
by 10% of them and you don't need to
keep big features that are only used
once dynamic features can be installed
and uninstalled dynamically when your
app requests them or you can choose to
defer installing to a later time when
the app goes to the background Facebook
was one of our launch partners and they
are using dynamic features in production
in the main Facebook app and in Facebook
light for example card scanning is a
feature that only a small percentage of
Facebook's user base is using so moving
it to a dynamic feature avoids it taking
up almost 2 megabytes on each user's
device within an app bundle installed
and instant apps can share the same base
module and the same dynamic feature
modules so separating out functionality
as a dynamic feature is a great way to
get your base small enough to offer an
instant app experience
now you can start building and testing
dynamic features using Android studio
3.2 today and you can join our beta and
become whitelisted to publish them to
production now I'd like to invite or
Ashley Boyd up to tell us more about app
updates
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome thanks Matt so yeah we've heard
your feedback that you'd like more
control to ensure that users are running
the latest and greatest version of your
app to address this I'm excited to
announce the Google Play in-app update
API the update API has two variants the
first is an immediate update flow where
the user is presented with a full screen
experience they can accept the update
have it downloaded installed immediately
before proceeding many of you have
already implemented similar variants of
this in your app but this new
streamlined implementation is less
error-prone and super easy to integrate
next is flexible updates flexible
updates are really cool because they
actually allow the the update experience
to be integrated into your app and it
feels far more customized as an example
Google Chrome is opted to nudge users to
update what the small affordance if the
user accepts that update the download
happens in the background and the user
can continue to use your app when the
download is complete it's up to you as
the developer to decide if you'd like
the update to be applied immediately by
presenting an affordance or if you'd
simply like the update to be applied the
next time the app is in the background
Google Chrome is testing this now and
we're excited to be expanding the early
access program coming soon next instant
apps instant apps are now available on
over 1.3 billion devices helping more
users discover your apps we've been hard
at work on simplifying the development
experience for instant apps
earlier this year we increase the size
limit for in snaps from 4 megabytes to
10 megabytes and what we found is that
just by using the Android app bundle
many developers are already able to get
under that size limit without additional
work
additionally the dynamic features that
Matt mentioned earlier are also instant
compatible so you get two-for-one
savings we've also made it possible to
now upload and test in synapse of any
size this allows you to both iterate on
the user experience at the same time
that you're optimizing for size and
we've also made web URLs optional
what this means is that you can now just
take your existing Play Store deep link
traffic and reroute those users into
your instant experience automatically
and lastly I'm excited to announce that
today in Android studio 3.3 beta you can
now have a single Android studio project
that houses both your instant and
installed apps this dramatically
simplifies the development experience
for instant apps and additionally the
app bundle that's emitted by this
project can be uploaded once to the Play
Developer console dramatically
simplifying release management as well
we're super excited about it and with
that back to Steph
[Music]
[Applause]
Android's open source and scale means
it's incredible to watch what you're
building on top of the platform with
over two billion devices three quarters
of a trillion apps downloaded every year
and developers in 194 countries
Android's developer community is growing
hugely in countries like India and
Brazil we saw it more than double just
in the past few years so we're seeing
innovation on Android worldwide androids
not a conventional operating system in
how we work with developers we want to
get your input in our gde community in
open source collaborations like the
Kotlin foundation and we want to be open
in new places like our medium developer
channel it's by developers for
developers to share more technical
behind the scenes today and tomorrow
about 500 members of the team are here
we'll have over 30 sessions of technical
content it's live streamed and on
YouTube so the whole community can
participate we feel lucky to be a part
of it so that's it for the keynote thank
you I hope you enjoy Android dev summit
[Music]